Salah satu bidang di mana pengkomputeran kuantum boleh membantu pembelajaran mesin
adalah berkaitan dengan fungsi kernel atau
matriks kernel — jom kita terokai apa itu semua
dan kenapa kita perlukan ia. Untuk tu, kita akan imbas kembali
tiga perkara: kenapa hasil darab titik muncul dalam pembelajaran mesin,
kenapa masalah pembelajaran mesin melibatkan dimensi yang tinggi,
dan apa itu fungsi kernel.
Ingat balik bahawa hasil darab titik atau hasil darab dalam
vektor nyata n dimensi a
dan b diberikan oleh hasil darab magnitud a,
magnitud b, dan kosinus sudut theta iaitu sudut
antara keduanya. Ini sama dengan mendarabkan
setiap komponen a dengan komponen yang sepadan bagi
b dan menjumlahkannya. Ambil perhatian bahawa jika vektor-vektor itu
hampir ortogon, seperti apabila a
mempunyai komponen sifar di mana b mempunyai komponen yang besar,
hasil darab titik akan jadi kecil. Ini bersamaan dengan
theta yang menghampiri pi bahagi dua.
Sebaliknya, jika a mempunyai komponen negatif manakala b
mempunyai komponen positif,
bermakna vektor-vektor itu menghala ke
arah yang hampir bertentangan,
dan theta hampir kepada pi,
hasil darab titik boleh jadi
negatif. Akhir sekali, jika a mempunyai komponen besar di mana b
juga mempunyai komponen besar dengan tanda yang sama,
maknanya vektor-vektor itu hampir selari dan theta menghampiri sifar,
hasil darab titik akan jadi besar
dan positif. Jadi memang masuk akal untuk jangkakan bahawa hasil darab titik
akan jadi ukuran persamaan yang berguna
dalam titik data. Tidak semua data n dimensi
boleh dipisahkan dengan mudah dalam potongan n tolak
satu dimensi — maksudnya garisan,
satah, atau hiperplan. Kalau data tak terpisah dengan baik
dalam n dimensi, kita boleh benamkan titik data
dalam dimensi yang lebih tinggi, katakan m dimensi, di mana m
lebih besar daripada n. Ini dipanggil pemetaan ciri,
selalu ditandakan sebagai x ke phi x, di mana
phi x ialah pemetaan dari nombor nyata n dimensi ke
nombor nyata m dimensi.
Ini paling mudah digambarkan dengan
melengkungkan set data satu dimensi ke dalam
dua dimensi, atau mengambil data dua dimensi
dan menanamkannya dalam tiga dimensi.
Tapi dalam praktiknya, kita selalu benamkan data dalam ruang dengan ribuan
atau bahkan jutaan dimensi.
Hasil darab titik vektor tiga dimensi berbanding hasil darab titik
vektor dua dimensi bukanlah perbezaan yang ketara,
tapi hasil darab titik vektor sejuta dimensi
jadi sama sekali tak praktikal
untuk diguna pada set data yang besar.
Jadi orang ramai cipta satu helah yang bijak.
Bagaimana kalau kita guna unjuran
ke dimensi yang lebih tinggi yang mempunyai bentuk yang sangat spesifik,
supaya hasil darab titik vektor dalam
dimensi lebih tinggi adalah fungsi mudah bagi
vektor dimensi rendah? Maksudnya, kita cari pemetaan
dari data x ke phi x dimensi tinggi,
supaya hasil darab dalam
ruang ciri diberikan oleh satu
fungsi mudah dalam data dimensi rendah.
Fungsi k ini dipanggil fungsi kernel.
Idealnya, kita nak fungsi kernel ini
jadi fungsi hasil darab
dimensi rendah itu sendiri — yang akan bagi kita
yang terbaik dari kedua-dua dunia: ruang ciri berdimensi sangat tinggi,
tapi dengan hasil darab dalam yang mudah dan murah dikira.
Pada pandangan pertama, mungkin tak
jelas sama ada ini mungkin. Jom tengok
satu contoh mudah dalam dimensi yang sangat rendah.
Pertimbangkan pemetaan ciri khusus ini — ia memetakan
vektor tiga dimensi ke dalam
ruang sembilan dimensi. Rupanya,
hasil darab dalam bagi ruang ciri sembilan dimensi yang dipetakan
adalah sama dengan hasil darab dalam dalam ruang
tiga dimensi asal yang dikuasakan dua. Jadi hasil darab dalam
ruang yang dipetakan menggunakan fungsi phi
memerlukan pengiraan setiap
sembilan koordinat bagi
vektor pertama dan sembilan lagi bagi
vektor kedua, kemudian hasil darab dalam itu sendiri iaitu
sembilan lagi hasil darab dan penjumlahan —
jumlahnya dua puluh lapan operasi.
Fungsi kernel pula hanya perlukan tiga hasil darab
dan dua penjumlahan — hanya empat operasi sahaja.
Itu tadi untuk memetakan titik data tiga dimensi ke dalam
ruang ciri sembilan dimensi.
Mudah nampak betapa besarnya kelebihan ini
untuk ruang yang sangat besar.
Fungsi kernel biasanya ialah fungsi selanjar
yang boleh digunakan pada mana-mana vektor dalam dataset kita.
Kita guna fungsi kernel dengan mengambil
pasangan titik data dari set kita
sebagai argumen. Dengan menerapkan fungsi kernel pada
setiap pasangan titik data dalam set,
kita dapat matriks simetri yang dipanggil matriks
kernel. Jenis fungsi kernel yang digunakan bergantung pada
masalah kita. Jadi untuk rumuskan semula:
untuk huraikan persamaan antara vektor dalam dataset kita,
kita selalu perlukan hasil darab dalam. Hasil darab dalam dalam
ruang ciri berdimensi sangat tinggi jadi mahal pengiraannya,
jadi kita guna pemetaan ciri yang sepadan
dengan fungsi kernel khas tertentu
yang menjadikan pengiraan lebih cekap.
Tapi sekatan pada fungsi kernel khas ini
memang mengehadkan jenis pemetaan ke ruang ciri yang boleh
dibuat dengan cekap. Ini
mungkin menghalang kita daripada mengasingkan data dengan baik.
Kalau je ada cara lain...
Di sinilah pengkomputeran kuantum masuk.
Pemetaan ciri berdimensi sangat tinggi yang sepadan
dengan fungsi kernel boleh dijalankan
pada komputer kuantum dalam quantum kernel estimator.
Matriks kernel k dikira,
dan dari situ algoritma pembelajaran mesin klasikal boleh
digunakan. Untuk itu, satu titik data x satu
dimuatkan dan dipetakan, kemudian
x dua yang lain dimuatkan
dan dipetakan. Memandangkan hasil darab dalam dua keadaan kuantum
berkaitan dengan kebarangkalian pengukuran,
kita boleh anggaran hasil darab dalam dua titik data yang dipetakan
dengan membuat pengukuran yang cukup banyak pada
circuit yang terhasil. Dengan cara ini, circuit kita
boleh beritahu kita tentang hasil darab dalam
dalam mana-mana ruang berdimensi tinggi yang boleh dimodelkan oleh circuit itu,
tanpa kita perlu kira secara klasikal hasil darab dalam atau
fungsi kernel. Terdapat banyak cara untuk
menyesuaikan dan menambah baik kaedah-kaedah ini,
dan memang sentiasa ada kaedah baru yang dicadangkan
dan diuji. Kami harap
gambaran keseluruhan ini membantu dalam memahami
aplikasi pengkomputeran kuantum
dalam kaedah pembelajaran mesin,
terutamanya yang melibatkan kernel.